Let’s just cut to the chase, friends. While the
rest of the world is getting ready to see Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever in a few months, I’ve
got my eyes set to the movie right after it,
Ant-Man: Quantumania. Why should I care about
the third movie in the Ant-Man trilogy? Well,
because that’s where Ant-Man is going to
die. And I’m about to prove it to you.
Hello Internet. Welcome to Film Theory, where
the smallest details transform into HUGE pieces
of evidence. Case in point, today’s episode.
You see, even before this year’s ComicCon,
it’d been pretty well established that Kang
the Conqueror was gonna be the MCU’s next
Thanos-level, overarching threat. There’s
been no shortage of articles and interviews
confirming that when it comes to Marvel, THIS is
the guy that you're gonna need to watch out for.
And now that the next Avengers movie is straight
up called “The Kang Dynasty”? Forget about it,
case closed. So far, we’ve only gotten our
first tease of Kang in the MCU as this big,
over-excited exposition dump during the
final episode of Loki. But in the comics
he’s actually a multiversal warmonger, a guy who
lives with the unlimited lives cheat code on.
Not only does Kang have infinite violent
variants floating around the infinite timelines,
Kang’s future technology is so advanced that he’s
able to transfer his consciousness to a new body
at the moment of his death. The dude’s like Rick
Sanchez minus the existential apathy. And don’t
get me wrong, a Citadel of Ricks vs Avengers
showdown is certainly interesting in theory,
but it ultimately might ring hollow if there’s
no stakes behind it. Thanos wasn’t just an
era-defining villain because he was powerful. If
we learned anything from galaxy-brained Grimace,
a box office mega villain needs to earn their
place by altering the status quo drastically.
They need to prove that they’re a truly
existential threat to our favorite, plot-armored
heroes. They need to make our blood boil with the
rage of revenge and the fear of loss. In short,
someone’s gotta get dusted. Kang has to prove
himself as the next major threat by killing
off a beloved hero. And that hero, is going to be
Ant-Man. Yep, I predict that Ant-Man, in the final
movie of his trilogy, is going to get exterminated
like a bug...which y’know… is… it’s fitting.
First, let’s start things off by examining
the general story structure of the MCU.
Thanks for that, Kang. See? This guy
knows what he’s talking about. Now,
I mean absolutely no disrespect to Stan Lee stans
by this, but the MCU runs on some pretty tried
and true story formulas. At this point, I think
it’s pretty fair to say that we’re all at least
vaguely familiar with the narrative beats of
the iconic Hero’s Journey: A call to adventure,
find a mentor, death and rebirth that
results in some sort of a transformation,
atonement and then returning back to the
beginning changed as a result. Classic stuff,
been done to death. But, exactly like that,
overarching end bosses hit key beats in their
stories as well. You can certainly see the pattern
in self-contained stories, but it’s especially
apparent when you start looking at memorable
big baddies of epic adventure franchises. First,
the big villain appears in a film technique that
Steven Spielberg likes to call “the fraction
introduction”. This is where the audience is
teased about the mystery surrounding this new
character. For Thanos, this fraction tease came
as his cameo at the end of the first Avengers film
pegging him as the true mastermind behind Loki’s
Chitauri invasion. Harry Potter had evil Lord
Voldemort appearing as just a face on the back of
professor Quirrel's head at the end of the first
movie. Showing the big boss as the motivating
force for a lesser antagonist is a common trope
that’s used to express this particular plot point.
Think of Firelord Ozai’s silhouette ordering
Zuko to hunt down the Avatar, or Grand Moff
Tarkin name dropping the Emperor in a New Hope
Implying that even Darth Vader answers
to someone higher up on the food chain.
As a plot moves into Act 2, we’re given a taste of
the villain’s true power. It’s common for writers
to give us a hint of this through the use of
specific story beats known as “pinch points.”
These “pinch points” are moments that amp
up the narrative tension by putting our
heroes in a jam through increasing doses of the
villain’s intensifying presence. Traditionally
there are two major pinch points that happen on
opposite ends of a story’s second act. The first
is usually early in act 2 and is just a simple
reminder of the villain’s strength. The second
foreshadows the biggest complication that the
villain will throw at our heroes. Oftentimes,
an important character gets killed in the process.
In Harry Potter, the first key pinch showcasing
the threat of Voldemort is the death of Cedric
Diggory in Goblet of Fire. The second pinch point
comes when Dumbledore himself is killed off in
movie 6, right before the final push towards
the end battle. For the Infinity Saga, Thanos’
first pinch point comes when he enlists Ronan
the Accuser to get the Power Stone in Guardians of
the Galaxy. Through Ronan, we are given a glimpse
of the destruction that’ll spread throughout the
universe as Thanos completes his rock collection.
The second pinch point is at the start of Infinity
War when Thanos decimates the Asgardians, boxes
the previously unbeatable Hulk into retirement,
and drives home that even the slippery Loki can’t
escape his inevitability. Loki’s death is the
lynch pin of the pinch point; without it, the
stakes wouldn’t be high enough for the audience
to care. In one scene, Thanos decimates what have
otherwise been indestructible heroes, giving
us a sense of the real threat that he poses.
Which brings us then, to their moment of
victory. After years of scheming in the shadows,
the villain finally achieves their goal. When it
comes to sprawling franchise-level narratives,
this moment often happens in the second-to-last
installment, leaving us on a cliffhanger so that
both fans and heroes have to sit through their
darkest hour for years waiting for resolution.
Just think about the king of this trope: Star
Wars: The Empire Strikes Back where Han ends the
movie as a big ol’ ice cube and Luke loses a hand.
For the Infinity Saga, this moment is when Thanos
bests Earth’s mightiest heroes and dusts half the
universe. This structure achieves two purposes:
First it underlines the strength of the threat.
But more importantly, it turns our heroes into
underdogs. It’s not certain whether or not
they’ll be able to prevail. The next installment,
then, means that the heroes have to win back
every inch of the world that they wish to fix,
ultimately making the climactic
battle feel much more earned.
So, those are your “Lessons from the Screenplay”.
And, according to this time-tested story formula,
we can look at Kang’s confirmed appearances
in the MCU to deduce how he might be similarly
utilized across multiple movies in order to
truly rise to the role of the next big bad.
Right now, we’ve seen Kang’s first teaser
moment in the season 1 Loki finale,
and boy was that a journey on its own. Throughout
the season, we see timelines getting deleted,
Infinity Stones turned into meaningless rocks, and
a hangry cloud monster that devours all matter.
This leads to the Citadel at the End of Time,
a big scary castle with big dramatic doors and
massive tension-building elevators. With the
entire series building to this moment, Loki has
reached the one pulling the strings of the whole
operation. The elevator doors open and...KANG.
It’s his Thanos first reveal moment. And this
isn’t even a particularly violent Kang either.
Sure he’s created a Big Brother organization
run by puppets that prunes entire timelines,
but he tells us that all of this is to keep his
other, more violent selves at bay selves at bay
With just one timeline, there’s just one Kang,
and he warns that his death is gonna unleash a
Pandora’s box of crueler variants. So of course
he dies, only to have everything start to unravel.
Looking more broadly, right now, the multiverse
is in flux with movies like No Way Home
and Multiverse of Madness. While Kang isn’t
connected to either of those events…yet…those
movies are already priming us for Kang’s impending
multiversal war. We are learning the rules and the
dangers that accompany wild multiversal collisions
just like the Infinity Saga introduced us,
one by one, to the powers and dangers of
the individual stones via movies that were
completely disconnected from Thanos. The Reality
Stone in Thor 2, The Time Stone in Doctor Strange,
the tesseract in Avengers, the power stone
in Guardians. That way when everything comes
together with Kang, all the rule setting and world
building has already been done in previous movies.
All of this means that, if we consult
the handy-dandy story cheat sheet,
the next time we’ll be interacting with Kang will
be the “pinch points.” And, hey, wouldn’t you know
it but we have two projects next year to have
that pair of pinch points. One of these has to
be Loki Season 2, due out in mid-2023. This one’s
obvious because, at the end of Season 1 of Loki,
we see giant Kang statues in the new layout of
the rebooted TVA. It’s safe to say that Kang is
going to play a HUGE role in Loki’s return,
which means there’ll be plenty of time to
get one of those Pinches in. But the other pinch
point is going to come even sooner than that,
with Quantumania’s release in February of 2023.
And that one is going to be the DEATH PINCH!
This is wild
And here’s where the theory
gets interesting. Loyal Theorists, I submit to you
Exhibit A: A minor-leaked image from Quantumania’s
pre-production. These shirts were allegedly made
for Quantumania’s stunt team, depicting a broken
Ant-Man helmet, and the reflection of Kang the
Conqueror ominously charging an energy blast. Now,
third installments of MCU films historically
end with the destruction of a hero's iconic
equipment. Iron Man 3 had Tony hit the fireworks
button on his whole iron closet, Captain America:
Civil War had Steve Rogers renounce his
shield, and Thor Ragnarok shattered Mjolnir
like it was made out of Lego. What this means
is that Scott Lang might just be left to face
the nearly immortal time-demigod Kang with only
his wits, and ah…well, those aren’t great odds.
And I’m not the only one to notice the power
imbalance here. Back in October of 2021,
Jonathan Majors, actor for Kang the Conquerer,
was interviewed on the late night show Jimmy
Kimmel. When he’s questioned on how Ant-Man
would possibly be able to contend with
someone of Kang’s power, we get this:
“No offense to Ant-Man, but Kang…
Kang is a Thanos-lev... Yeah,
it’s like SQUASH. Ant-Man’s dead.
We’ll see”
Look at that face! Seems to me
that Kimmel guessed right, and Majors gives him a
little too much reveal with that facial response.
That, my friends is a man who has realized
that Kevin Feige’s snipers are on the way.
So, from a narrative angle, it’s the perfect
time for Ant-Man to die. We have Tshirts from
the production showing that Ant-Man is going to
get wrecked. And we have Kang’s actor giving us
some guilty vibes in interviews. But there’s still
one more piece of evidence that you need to see:
Avengers #500, the first part of the Avengers
Disassembled comic arc that brought about
the end of the Avengers team. Spoilers
Alert: In this issue, Ant-Man dies. Now,
admittedly it isn’t at the hands of Kang the
Conqueror but the ripple effects of his death
end up playing an important role in both Kang’s
development, and the evolution of the Avengers.
You see, Scott Lang’s death is very very comic
booky. He’s killed when the zombie corpse of
his best friend unexpectedly explodes. This all
turns out to be the result of a grieving Scarlet
Witch inadvertently tampering with the fabric
of reality. But it’s not the HOW of this comic
that’s important, it’s the WHY. You see, Scott’s
death is INCREDIBLY important because it’s the
catalyst that sets in motion the formation of the
Young Avengers. One of the key members is Scott’s
daughter Cassie Lang, who is so moved by Scott’s
death that she takes up the Ant-Man legacy under
the codename “Stature” and forms the team in order
to avenge him. And hey, wouldn’t you know it,
but the Quantumania poster and footage from
ComicCon showed us that Cassie is going to suit
up just like her dad in the new movie. Doesn’t
hurt that the Cassie actress from Endgame
also got recast with a bigger name, too… without
even telling said actress she was being recast.
Bad look there, Marvel. Bad look.
Now, it’s pretty clear that the Young
Avengers are coming to the big screen. Nearly
every Phase 4 property has introduced or will
introduce a potential Young Avenger, many of
whom are the founding members of the team in
the comics. WandaVision gave us Billy and
Tommy aka Wiccan and Speed. Hawkeye gave us
Kate Bishop. Loki opened the door for Kid Loki.
Multiverse of Madness gave us America Chavez,
and Falcon and the Winter Soldier gave us Patriot.
Heck, I wouldn’t be surprised if Hulkling pops up
in She-Hulk or Secret Invasion. Then you also
have to consider the potential applications of
Ms. Marvel and Ironheart, who are coming, and
teens and prime candidates for the MCU’s Young
Avengers line-up. Clearly, the building blocks
for this team are being assembled. Now we just
need the event that gets them all together
– Ant-Man’s death, just like in the comics.
But you want to know the real clincher? Kang is
actually the first villain that the Young Avengers
take on in the comics. It’s only fitting that
he play a role in their live-action debut. And
to go even more subatomic on this theory, if Kang
the Conqueror’s run-in with Ant-Man goes as badly
for Scott as I think it’s gonna, that one kill
doesn’t just mold the villain that all these new
heroes are going to have to band together against
in phase 5. It’s also going to shape the ENTIRETY
of phase six. What if, unlike Thanos, Kang gets
a redemption arc and becomes a Young Avenger?
You see, Kang has a zillion variants, but one
of them is a Young Avenger. In fact, he’s their
first leader. A teen variant of Kang going by
the alias Iron Lad forms the team in hopes that
he can divert himself from growing up to become
a megalomaniac that brings about the destruction
of the multiverse. Iron Lad even has a close,
sometimes romantic, relationship with Cassie Lang
in the comics. This poses an interesting conflict
if Kang turns out to be the one to squash Ant-Man.
At their core, the Ant-Man movies are thematically
about second chances. Scott is an ex-felon who’s
given a second-lease on life. Hank Pym gets
a second chance at saving his wife Janet.
The Ant-family helps save and redeem Ghost in
the second film. If Kang kills Cassie’s father,
she’s put in a scenario where she may have to
give her father’s killer a preemptive second
chance as well. So If Cassie chooses to forgive
young Kang, that may be the push Iron Lad needs
to avoid his dark future, saving the multiverse
from adult Kang in the process. Or maybe,
the second chance Kang gets in Quantumania
is at killing Scott… When they meet during
the trailer shown at ComicCon, Scott introduces
himself to Kang as an Avenger. Kang’s response?
“You’re an Avenger? Have I killed you before?”
So, when Ant-Man starts advertising itself like
yet another quirky superhero comedy starring
Paul Rudd, you’ll know the truth. At some point,
that thing is going to take a serious
turn and pull the rug out from under you,
stomping the main man himself out of existence.
Either that or…y’know…Ant-Man shrinks himself
and hops up Kang’s... But that’s just
a theory, a FILM THEORY…AAAAAND CUT!